"John Wick: Chapter 4" was a definitive finale for
the film series in more ways than one, but that
doesn't mean there aren't a few windows still
open that John could leap through at any time.
John Wick duels with Caine during the epic
conclusion of "John Wick: Chapter 4." And while
the hitman conspires to trick and ultimately
defeat the film's real villain, the Marquis
de Gramont, Wick succumbs to his wounds. However,
after the heartbreaking last moments of the movie,
there's a post-credits scene between Caine
and Akira that alludes to a possible spin-off,
but without the franchise's main character.
While producer Erica Lee seems to insist that
audiences should accept John Wick's tombstone at
face value, she's also not one to count the Baba
Yaga out. During an interview with "Collider,"
Lee asked and answered her own question, saying,
"I think that... is that character of John
Wick dead? Yes. Are there other versions or...
I don't know, I never say never. It's a long
life. We're developing other properties, too,
and I think that there's a lot of opportunity
for movies starring other characters or other
ways to worldbuild movies that are sort
of handovers to different characters."
Indeed, Wick might have perished during his
climactic battle at sunrise, but there's another
heavy hitter involved in the fight: the box
office. Within days of the movie's release,
"John Wick: Chapter 4" had already made over $150
million worldwide. And the latest installment
continues to win over both critics and audiences.
So, given all the spin-offs in development,
don't be surprised if Reeves returns in
the future, even if it's just as a cameo.
"The only way John Wick will ever
have freedom and peace, is in death."
Even though John Wick is dead, the
franchise is moving forward. First up,
there's the television mini-series "The
Continental." That will be followed by the
feature film titled "Ballerina." Interestingly,
taking a look at "Ballerina's" credits on IMDb,
Keanu Reeves is listed as a cast member. Because
the movie takes place between the third and
fourth films, it's reasonable to believe
that John Wick could show up in the Ana de
Armas-led project. Erica Lee further cemented the
connection between the two films when she said,
"Making 'Ballerina' has actually been a really
interesting process because it's a lot of the
stuff that we take from the 'John Wick'
movies. But then it's slightly different.
It's been fun to work on 'John Wick 4'
and 'Ballerina' kind of simultaneously,
and the TV show ['The Continental'], it's a lot
of Wick, but a lot of different versions of it."
Erica Lee isn't the only "John Wick: Chapter
4" producer leaving the door open for more
Keanu Reeves in the franchise's future.
Producer Basil Iwanyck spoke to IndieWire
about the film's final moments and what
it could mean for the character's future,
stating, "It's an ambiguous ending."
Seeing John Wick's grave certainly
leaves an emotional impact no one would want
to diminish, and it's clear if Wick's going
to return to this world of violence,
it has to be done in the right way.
After all, the movie shows Wick collapsing on
a staircase before cutting away to his grave
in a cemetery. A lot could've happened between
those two scenes, so there's room for Wick to
still be alive out there somewhere. Iwanyck
confirms that ambiguity was intentional:
"I don't think we've boxed
ourselves into any corner,
whether he's dead or alive,
at the end of this movie."
With so many spinoffs in the works, you
better believe that if those pulling the
strings think they can make bank by bringing
Keanu Reeves back, they'll do everything they
can to convince the star to put on his
kevlar-lined suit jacket one more time.